good evening I'm Laura welcher I'm the
director of the Rosetta project at the
long now foundation and for those of you
who are unfamiliar thank you for those
of you who are unfamiliar with the
Rosetta project the project is long now
Foundation's first exploration into very
long term information archiving and the
work we're doing is to build a
collection of the world's nearly 7,000
languages many of which are rapidly
going extinct so we're trying to
document them and archive information
about them as quickly as we can and
there's a digital side to the Rosetta
project and we have lots of text
documents and audio recordings and video
recordings and we make those all
publicly available through the the
generosity of brewster kahle at the
Internet Archive where we have special
collections there and we also have
there's another side to the Rosetta
project which is a very long term analog
backup of the collection and that is the
Rosetta disk and you can see a little
bit of the Rosetta disk on this slide
here and the Rosetta disk is actually a
physical object and it has between
13,000 and 14,000 pages on it that are
pages of documentation on human language
on over 1,500 human languages actually
and they're microscopically formed into
the nickel the solid nickel itself and
you read it it's not a 1 0 so it's not
digital you read it like you would read
a book and all you need to do it is a
microscope that can do optical
magnification of about 500 power and
when you look at it through a microscope
you can read it just like you could read
the pages of the book and the idea is
that this is a physical version of the
archive that could last and be still
readable and legible for thousands of
years
and we've made just a very few
prototypes of this disc that we've made
available and just very recently we have
engineered a special edition a special
version of this disc that we're now
making available as a special numbered
Edition and we're making it available to
people who sign up as ten thousand year
members of the long now foundation so
these are the discs that are out there
in the world today it's like I said
there's just a very few of them
why does with William lid well who is
who has written a book the principles
universal principles of design there's
another that is on public display at the
University of Colorado Boulder in the
Special Collections library and that was
through a gift of the lazy eight
foundation one of the first foundations
that supported our work one is in
Germany with the Oliver Vilkas shift
over Spartan one we presented to dr.
Wayne Clough when he gave his talk
Smithsonian forever as part of the
series in 2009 and that is destined for
the National anthropological archives
it's currently on display at the Museum
Castle so if you go to the visit the
castle you could ask to see the rosetta
disk there and a one is with Brewster
Kahle of the Internet Archive and he was
the the person who first suggested this
technology to us and one of our earliest
supporters and there's also some disc
material and one copy of the rosetta
disk that's out there in space and so
very very recently we had the
opportunity to test some of the
materials of the disc to see how they
would last we have learned that if
there's ever an opportunity to send
anything into space
say yes so we've tested some of the
materials and they've come back and you
can read about that on our blog there
but the the disc that's out there in
space is on a European Space Agency
mission
it was launched around 2004 and the disk
is on the craft itself and the the
mission is to send a craft in orbit with
a comet and there's going to be a part
of the craft that's actually going to
land on the comet and relay information
back to the earth it's the first time
we've we have ever attempted to do this
and there's a rosetta disk on board that
orbiter so it's going to be out there
and orbiting with that comment for we
don't know how long but it's out there
and if you want to read up on it you can
go to the European Space Agency website
and track it and then you can think
there's a rosetta Scout there so um so
once again this is this new specially
engineered version of the disc is
available for 10,000 year membership in
the long now foundation and that's
really a lifetime membership and that's
for so we we wish our members a very
very happy healthy long life and that
membership is for a one-time donation of
$10,000 to support the organization and
and to honor your commitment to our
organization we're going to use that to
build long-term financial support and
sustainability for the foundation for
our outreach and our programs like this
one tonight and also for the Rosetta
project thank you
[Applause]
thanks Laura
as you can tell Laura dinelli in charge
of the Rosetta project and the languages
and so on she's a professional linguist
she's also in charge of program
development and fundraising by the way
if you live to be eleven thousand years
you've got to re-up but we assume you'll
have been doing good investments over
that time and it won't cost you that
much we're coming up on the hundredth
one of these seminars about long term
thinking and so it's appropriate to have
somebody who's been with us from the
start
formerly the long now foundation started
in 1996 in the Presidio the Internet
Archive formally started in 1996 in the
Presidio by the time we got to the year
2000 and our first prototype of the
clock was finished just in time to bomb
twice for the 2,000 years on the night
of 2000 AD we were in Brewster Cales
Internet Archive building in the
Presidio and so we've been pretty much
marching in step ever since it's no
accident that the the way you access the
Rosetta disk could you connect with
languages we thought this language thing
this presented this thing was going to
be kind of a short term project that you
know we would spin off like we've spun
off other things but language is in fact
long term thinking it's how humans
basically managed cognitive stuff over
centuries in millennia the languages
express that and losing a language is
losing that kind of duration that kind
of world and we are losing languages so
recording them all now is an important
long-term project both reaching all the
way back into the origins in the history
of language and reaching all the way
forward to curiosity that people are
going to have about these languages
presumably indefinitely
so if you want to see the rosetta
archive real online in real time you go
to the Internet Archive where it is and
then there's a backup down at Stanford
Brewster Kahle is also part of one of
our first conferences called time and
bits the problem is that time and bits
don't like each other digital stuff
tends to be inaccessible after just a
couple of years and one of the things
that everybody said back then as well
for sure everything that's on the
internet is going to go away and dead
links and you know just it's gone
Brewster pointed out at that time that
the life of something on the Internet is
just a few months typically and that was
understood to be an in solvable problem
we were wrong about that and Brewster
Kahle will say no only why that's the
case but why lots of other things to the
case Brewster
thank you it's fabulous to be here I do
think the Internet Archive and the long
now project are partners we have in
parallel missions and sort of grant
pieces of aspirations towards doing
things or being a part of things that
can see the whole whether it's all time
all distance all knowledge the Internet
Archive that I'm going to describe some
of the projects there but more generally
what's going on in libraries and
knowledge and information we're really
striving to build the Library of
Alexandria version to the Library of
Alexandria version one 300 BC strove to
have all the books of all the peoples of
the world but you had to go to
Alexandria to be able to to read them we
have an opportunity that doesn't come up
very often to try to one-up the Greeks
can we make it so that everyone anywhere
that's curious enough to want to have
access can have access to the world's
knowledge and that's what I'm going to
try to describe that the idea of
universal access to all knowledge is
within our grasp that not only is this
doable but as a whole where we're
starting to get there and it's a
worthwhile project and technologically
financially and probably most
importantly legally we can get there the
idea of all the books music video web
pages whatever everything made by people
is possible to go and make available to
anybody anywhere at any time
so that's the that's my goal out of
tonight is to argue that not only is
this possible it's a good project to be
involved in and frankly try to recruit
some of you to help so Internet Archive
we're a nonprofit library we're
independent of the government or of
governments or universities but we're
sort of within the the culture of the
museums or university structures within
the United States this is our
headquarter building over in San
Francisco
and we have satellites and lots of other
places we see ourselves in embedded in
the library world and I like looking at
things that people have carved in stone
things that people have carved in stone
they want you to know lasts a long time
it's sort of important to them so over
the Boston Public Library this is a
institution that was built at the height
of the robber baron era in the United
States and actually funded by those guys
and they carved free to all so even in
probably the most capitalist property
oriented country Society ever built
there's something special about
libraries they're a bit about how we
work as a people and so we see ourselves
within that tradition but if we're gonna
try to go and do the whole damn thing
let's try to break it down into pieces
how big is it how hard is it um what can
we do to try to get there so I'm gonna
do sort of like in the amazon.com
website books music video and go over
each of these to sort of get an idea of
so where are we at this point so texts
if you wanted to put all the texts
online well you have to ask sort of well
how much is there um and how hard would
it be the largest library in the world
is the Library of Congress Library
Congress between 26 and 28 million
volumes and it's an unbelievable
collection but it's larger than by far
than the next libraries down and a book
is about a megabyte if you had a book in
Microsoft Word it's about a megabyte so
26 million megabytes it goes million
megabytes gigabytes terabytes so it's
about 26 28 terabytes that's about this
big you can put in a single shopping
cart and Best Buy uh and not go
completely broke you can have all of the
words in the Library of Congress and it
you know would be kind of this big all
right it's been for a while but it would
all be accessible and if you had a
powerful enough machine its searchable
that's pretty cool so the idea of having
it all there
is is as doable then the question is
what do you get I mean is it worth doing
and I think over the last bunch of years
we've started getting the idea yeah we
want to have books online and we want
even old books online we want all books
online and they're starting to be
different interfaces to them some of the
first were these very book looking
interfaces that you know how these sort
of page turning point of view and you
and you'll see a lot more of that but on
the other hand books are sometimes the
right codex's printed materials are
sometimes the right way to carry things
around on us in Alexandria Egypt
helping rebuild the new Library of
Alexandria which was a great honor I got
to meet with one of the benefactors mrs.
Mubarak and she said but I love my books
and I understood that yeah okay we're
gonna have to go and print the books
back out again so I said okay give us a
few years a few months and we'll come
back and make a bookmobile work so this
is a print-on-demand bookmobile so you
can download print and bind a book and a
book but a short book um cost about a
buck a book at a buck a book to download
print and bind means you can give books
away that they don't become rare
resources anymore in some fundamental
sense and they start looking pretty good
and actually I brought a bunch so if you
pass them around and if you really like
I'm just put one in your pocket because
frankly it only cost me a buck a book so
so the idea is you can actually print
these things back out again there are
now a couple of these in India this is
the first day at the Library of
Alexandria when we were doing it in a
nearby school this is an engineer
working with a kid and this is the first
book this kid has ever owned so the idea
of having these libraries in digital
form might have kind of old-fashioned
service models that are enabled by it
which I kind of took is surprising at
first being kind of a geek but it does
make a whole
lotta sense and we tried one others
launching it in rural Uganda so we put
the first internet connection into the
national library of Uganda and tried out
this technology to go and go out to the
areas and try to find could this
technology work what we did find is yes
the technology worked but we didn't have
the right books that we really needed to
go back and figure out how to get newer
books textbooks things like that in
copyright books available and all hit
more of those issues in a moment but
delivering was getting to be possible
here's a new robot
it's the mazing Rube Goldberg machine
that basically goes in has a printer and
as a cover printer and it glues the the
binding and wraps it around and um goes
around and chops it and out comes a book
so the idea of of doing print-on-demand
books that look like books is all around
in good shape um I'm actually pretty
psyched about some of these newer
devices you know this is the One Laptop
Per child that's now and I think it's in
five million children's hands that
around the world now every kid in Uganda
at a certain age has one of these things
and that can make it so that they can
have access to enormous collections of
books and of course we've started to see
more of tablets and we've made all of
the books we've scanned you know swooosh
herbal and searchable in these
particular domains and gosh these things
never stop so one thing I've found is if
you're gonna build a digital library you
better be pretty active going and
reformatting things over and over and
over again so the one in the bottom
corner I really like is is a little
device for blind and dyslexic people you
download a book to it even if they're
encrypted because of the laws and you
can it will read a little bit like this
and what they really like is you can
have it read a little bit like this and
it can go very very fast so actually the
largest library in digital form is
available to the blind and dyslexic
just because of the copyright allows
everything to be available to them which
I find actually is a as a good social
justice then the question okay now if
we've got it so we'd actually want these
things online how do we get it there
and we've been involved in a bunch of
different projects this is the from the
million books project well we got a
bunch of scanners for Library of
Alexandria and they put them into India
and China
this guy doesn't look too thrilled about
it it does take a certain level of Zen
to scan books
but you basically turn the pages
photograph the pages and then process
them and make them readable we found
that this technology didn't make for
very good looking books so we designed
our own system that holds a book like
this so it doesn't break the binding and
it raises the lowers glass to flatten it
and takes two pictures and a person
turns pages and a person can basically
digitize between one and two books an
hour and that's about what it takes to
basically get a book so it's in
beautiful form then you can take those
images you have to do all sorts of QA to
make sure you didn't lose any pages and
you straighten them out do all of that
kind of thing read the pages so you can
search it and use it in new in different
ways
and then make it into PDFs and Kindle
books and nook books and you know blind
and disabled on dyslexic books and bump
up up up up up up up and all of that
process can can be done at this sort of
speed we now have 29 scanning centers in
six countries and we're scanning over a
thousand books a day so the idea of
being able to do this at scale is as as
possible it cost us about 10 cents a
page or about $30 a book so in 300 page
book to digitize a book if you take all
told it's probably $40 in terms of all
of the handling and the whole shebang so
the idea of digitizing things on Moss is
quite doable another project that we've
started up is to digitize all of the
publications ever done in balinese so
the first whole language that may be
complete the whole language everything
published in it might be Balinese I also
find kind of cool and it's a large part
because they just said you want to scan
all of our stuff absolutely let's do it
well how can we help
um and so these guys are our scanning
away there are a couple libraries and
what they publish on our palm leaves
because in uh in an area that it's a
jungle paper doesn't work very well so
it's palm leaves that are scratched into
and the way that they're read is their
son and their son by priests and this
language is spoken by 2 or 3 million
Balinese but it is going away because
the Indonesians are basically putting in
Indonesian instead of Balinese so we
hope that this is a mechanism of keeping
the diversity of languages going just as
Stuart and Laura were referring to and
the materials are just fantastic so now
we've got all these scanning centers all
over the world starting to chug along um
and doing about a thousand books a day
we could do quite a bit more and it's
just funding limited and we're starting
to get over the hurdles of sort of why
would you want to do this and people are
saying ok now how do we do this
faster we're up to about three million
texts that are available on the internet
archive site for free downloading no
restrictions just go nuts which is
pretty pretty darn great we have two
hundred and fifty thousand modern books
that are available to the blind and
dyslexic and a hundred thousand modern
e-books that are available through a
lending library it starts to get a
little tricky the google book project i
was running along with some great
libraries and they ran headlong into a
lawsuit that and these libraries tried
to do a kind of interesting game to go
and build a subscription-based system as
a way of settling the lawsuit and the
justice department said that was a
bridge too far that's a monopoly let's
not let's not go there
and that whole project is sort of
stalled so there's another approach
which is to really act like a library
and lend things um so I'll say a little
bit more about about that but I'd say we
have about eight million books to go if
what we're trying to build is a Boston
Public Library or a Yale or a print
and that's about a 10 million volume
project about 10 million volumes I'd say
we're about 2 million volumes into it
even though there are 303 million texts
about to me so I'd say we have about 8
million to go and if we were to sort of
just write the check what does it cost
it's about a hundred and sixty million
dollars at this point if we knew all of
it was coming through to be able to do
the Rd so that's a big number but it's
not an unbelievable number the libraries
in the United States are is about a
twelve billion dollar a year industry
about three or four billion dollars goes
to publishers products so the idea of a
one-time cost of 160 million to be able
to get basically the whole darn thing
online in terms of books is is within
our grasp then there's a question how do
you deal with some of the copyright
issues we built a site called open
library org and it's the idea is to have
one web page for every book ever
published and if it's available from
someplace to buy or to borrow or to
download that you can have links to it
we use the site to build this lending
library so we're working with libraries
around the world to make it so they
contribute in copyright books that are
digitized and made part of a pool and
then if you're in one of these libraries
you can have access to the whole pool
and we now have a thousand libraries
participating putting books that are in
copyright into this pool and then we
lend it one person at a time sort of
clunky sort of wrapping ourselves in the
old-style library
you know white you know why you make
that limitation well cuz there's a
tradition around it and the other guys
are still in court so the idea is to try
to the idea is to try to find a way
through this thicket and so what does
lending look like if you walk into any
of the Boston Public Library libraries
and you go to the borrow borrow pages or
if you go into any of that well I'll get
to that in a minute but anyway libraries
around here as well you can click on hey
there's this html5 for web designers and
we bought this book and we bought this
book from a publisher such that we could
lend it and so you can say oh I want to
this book but it says oh it's checked
out yeah darn and then you can add it to
your list and remind yourself to go and
get it some other time
if you go back out and say oh well I
really wanted this Mayflower descendants
book that was contributed by the Boston
Public Library
um it was published in 1994 and they
digitized their copy kept their copy to
the side and they're lending it
digitally so there are one person at a
time from the Boston Public Library
through the open library site you can
say oh gosh I want to see it in these
different formats do I want to download
it onto my kindle or or my my nook or do
I want to read it in a browser I want to
read it in a browser and it says that
it's it's coming from the Boston Public
Library so we're really happy that
basically our libraries are sort of
walking arm-in-arm and saying these
digital things may not be as different
from the physical world as we used to
think let's go and at least not lose
what we had in the physical world as we
move forward and then let's try to make
gains beyond that so then we can check
these objects these things out and it's
all all free how libraries giant is they
send email to a head of books at the
archive they contribute at least one
modern book they commit all of their
public domain books to be freely
available and they send the IP addresses
and blammo um we turn it on and I'd like
to announce tonight that's actually kind
of fun that um based on the good work of
say C ultra SH who's the state librarian
in California she said why don't we just
turn on not only everybody in every
public library in California but
everybody that's in California I'm the
librarian of California why don't we
just make California a big library we
said well that's a great idea so um so
this afternoon we made it so that if
you're a resident of say if your IP
addresses or you're coming from
California you'll be able to get any of
the hundred thousand books by going to
the open library for free so that's kind
of cool today
[Applause]
we hope to be turning on more states at
a time and maybe whole countries at a
time but it's basically showing a large
number of people working together to
make a model that works all the way
around we buy books from publishers that
are new we scan our older stuff and all
the really old things the public domain
we give away completely so all in all
it's working the idea of taking all the
books ever published digitizing them
putting them on disk making them
available whether they ain't copyrighted
Cobra is within our grasp and there's
good progress being made so that now
let's go on let's not stop there what
about all the audio of the world well um
as best I can tell out of all of the
discs in the world so the the 78
long-playing records or CDs they're
about 2 to 3 million that have been
published sort of through the 20th
century which is when those things you
know they're still being made but
they're kind of on their way out um and
but that that era is sort of 2 to 3
million that's doable
except it's a very heavily litigated
area so we've tried to find things that
people would be happy about sharing and
we found that there's lots of nooks and
crannies on that isn't putting Britney
Spears or Lady gaga
up on the line too that people want to
have access to um and they're all
everybody's all-around happy so what we
did is we said well I don't we're a
library we have cultural materials on
our shelves why don't we take anybody
that has materials that's okay to share
and offer them unlimited storage
unlimited bandwidth forever for free and
so
and we started doing this and the
rock-and-rollers took us up on it so the
UM the Grateful Dead started a tradition
of allowing people to record their
concerts and trade tapes nobody could
make any money on it you couldn't even
charge postage for the for the you know
in terms of when you're trading Grateful
Dead tapes but no one so nobody made any
money but it allowed the culture to
spread these archivists are fanatics um
and so we we said okay this tapir
community moved online and we're trading
it via FTP about ten years ago but they
could never keep things up on their
servers very very long because their
system administrators would go and yell
at them they'd have to take it back off
again so I'll there was an intern that
worked at the archive and he said you
know it's still going on are you really
up for this yeah yeah they said okay so
we wrote the paper email list uh a
letter you know and they wrote back we
don't believe you but if you could do it
it would be our dream always a good sign
if somebody says it'll be their dream um
so he said try us we thought it was
different from tape trading so we asked
for some level of permission from the
band's you know this isn't signed in
triplicate just have somebody say it's
okay um and so we get started getting
three bands a day signing up and about
40 or 50 concerts being uploaded in full
on full res downloadable okay as long as
nobody gets paid for and we now have
over a million recordings and a hundred
thousand concert recordings and
everything the Grateful Dead has ever
done so all in all we're finding ways to
make the whole thing work in terms of
digitizing discs if there are two to
three million of them it costs us about
10 to 20 dollars depending on how
complicated the disc is to be able to
digitize it so all in all again that's
maybe 20 or 30 million dollars to go
through the discs and then there's other
collections the mp3 coms and the like
that are
easier to pick up that is possible to
get these things online exactly how to
do the distribution on the commercial
materials we haven't quite figured out
we now have over a million audio items
and a hundred collections spanning from
news to lectures two different kinds of
audio and seventy-eights and all sorts
of different kinds of things so the idea
of not only books but audio being doable
is within our grasp as well moving
images well can we do moving images no
how many are there well most people
think of moving images as theatrically
produced movies and our Rick Prelinger
estimation is there are about 150,000 to
200,000 of them and about half of them
are Indian but that's a sort of a doable
scope most of these things are still
under copyright a lot of them are not
being actively promoted anymore
but we found about a thousand so far
that are not under copyright so we made
those available but the thing that we
found out of the moving images
experience is the other stuff it's the
one or two million 20th century moving
images that were done for some form of
public release but not really not meant
for theaters um educational films
advertisements government films those
sorts of things and working with Rick
Prelinger who's who's doing the lost
landscapes series who's been collecting
these things he said you know people are
really going to want those it's like
those films really I mean those were the
types of films about physics or about
you know do you want to be a type a
typesetter or those sorts you know why
not to hitchhike whatever those sorts
those things that in junior high school
and you're had a substitute teacher they
wheeled in the projector those so we
have those and people download these
things by the millions and I'm not quite
sure why I think they they maybe they
make new film
out of them yes they mean sort of video
wallpaper yes sort of kitsch yes but
this sort of material is actually much
more popular than I ever thought and it
is now a lot of it on the Internet
Archive and it's very inexpensive when
we figured out mechanisms to go in and
bring the song on board then we started
to go and let other people upload stuff
well there's whole genres I'd never idea
whatever exists like Lego movies oh if
you take um still uh cameras and and
take pictures again anyway uh and you
put a soundtrack on it presto movie it's
a whole genre and they found us because
we were doing free hosting um and large
part of YouTube has come about since we
started this and has done most of the of
the video archiving and actually thank
God um but at least the longer form and
more scholarly things are still going to
the Internet Archive we're starting to
work with 8 millimeter and 16 million
lot of home movies and trying to bring
personal materials online and so that
type of thing is is quite doable and
this is our first scanner towards doing
that so the idea is to try to find a
mechanism of taking all the moving
images whether it's on video tape or
film or aren't hard drives and make them
available and we're finding that the
costs is is doable and if you stay away
from some of the hot-button commercial
items um the idea of having these things
out there is becoming much more common
and ok then there's television so in
1990 in 1976 there was a law that was
passed that said the library Congress is
supposed to archive of American
television and then they published a
report in 1996 saying we didn't and
alright and I remember talking to Stuart
brand about this around the year
1999-2000 he just said why don't you
just hit the record button and that's
you know sort of a Stewart Brand thing
to say uh and so we did um and so we
started in the year 2000 recording 20
channels of
television twenty four-hours-a-day DVD
quality Russian Chinese Japanese Iraqi
Al Jazeera BBC CNN ABC Fennessy Fox just
burn and just recording it it was kind
of a headache at the time I was like a
very big TiVo box um it wasn't very
accessible when the 9/11 event happened
you know everybody's sort of trying to
think you know what can we do to help
you know does the world hate us whatever
so we we took one week of television
news September 11th 2001 to September
17th 2001 just before the first planes
went in and we got those back online
this is in 2001 and on October 11th 2001
we put it all up on the net and
basically said here's what the world saw
and here's what their reaction was there
are folks on American TV saying that
Palestinians were dancing in the streets
were they let's look at Palestinian
television at this point I think we
really understand that television comes
with a point of view um and if you're
going to think critically you need to be
able to compare and contrast and quote
these are you know what we learned in
high school but we really impossible to
do on in television it just kind of
flows past except if you're John Stewart
or it's you know what does he choice
anyway I want everybody to be a Jon
Stewart research department so that you
can basically go back and see what
people said you know contrast and
compare and be able to go and use and
critically think about such an important
medium and so we've done a little bit
towards that with the 9/11 collection
and we're looking to do more
hopefully for this next election that is
coming up but if you go into the our
internet archive this is really fun
interface for zipping around and looking
at a medley very grim material um but in
a new and different way to be able to
look at material from around the world
and be able to to hopefully make some
sense of it so the idea of archiving all
moving images we found to be within our
grasp that the idea of taking videotapes
cost-effectively to be able to go and
down digitize these make these available
even all of television for a small group
like us we are now up to around a
hundred channels of television that
we're recording 24 hours a day is doable
and within our grasp then the question
is how much access can we do in such a
way that we don't disturb the applecart
too much and try to make it said
everybody's happy as we're moving into
an era era when we can use moving images
as a medium of record so moving images
we're doing fairly well 500,000 in lots
of different collections and the like so
books music video starting to be doable
if you do allow people to upload to your
site you sometimes attract unwanted
patrons such as the FBI so on the if the
FBI sent us one of those nasty grams
called a national security letter a
national security letter is a beast that
came out of the out of the patriot act
where they're allowed to demand
information from all sorts of people and
you can never tell anybody anything
about it it's really completely bizarre
so they came and they wanted to hand
this to us so we sent them to our
lawyers the Electronic Frontier
Foundation uh-huh and they received this
thing and they came over and said well
you're gonna have to just comply and
never tell anybody about it or you can
push back and I said how do you push
back and said well it's not easy you
have to sue the United States government
because there really is no provision to
go and appeal you just have to sue them
so we sued the United States government
to the and we basically wanted to make a
cookbook for the other people that might
be getting these and can't talk to
anybody about them I couldn't talk to my
board couldn't talk to anybody I
couldn't talk to my wife and kids about
this um but the ACLU and EF F are
engaged in a six six month
secret court case to basically take this
thing out and a turnout they they really
didn't need to know the information that
much as it stood which is but anyway
they basically wanted to cave
immediately and we wouldn't let them off
the hook we basically said not only do
we want this thrown out is we want to be
able to tell everybody about it and we
want to publish all of the documents and
make it so that except for who what the
patron that you were after is we wanted
to go and make a cookbook for other
people to follow and we want the less
the lesson for me out of this was that
we really do need to bring some of the
traditions of the past into the digital
world that the digital world isn't
necessarily as different as you know we
shouldn't rewrite all the rules there's
a bunch of things that we learned by
running libraries over the last couple
thousand years let's not forget them now
okay so on the closer to the last one
software titles they're about 50,000
software titles we're collecting a lot
of them but we need help to go and get
them online and get them bundled into
emulators so that people can still use
them well we're probably best known for
is collecting the World Wide Web
so I help try to get this this there's
publishing stuff to go on the internet
so that we could build this library the
the web was starting to come around and
so we started collecting the world wide
web one copy of every page from every
website every two months we basically
sent out these robots to click on every
link and record what it is they they saw
on two hard drives and then after two
months start again so just click lick
lick lick lick lick like oh and it's
starting to get big it wasn't that bad
when we started um I remember going and
visiting the Alta Vista search engine
and uh it was a real light bulb go on
time when you could look at the web and
it was about the size of two Coke
machines and that was the sort of the
size of the web at the time about 30
million pages was part of the Alta Vista
search engine and I think January of
of 1996 and so I said okay that's we can
do that um so we started collecting the
web this is what Yahoo looked like in
1996 very clean kind of like Google
today um I I love the dreamers um this
is the sock puppet the pets.com guys oh
there's do you guys remember the warm
cookies and milk um they would deliver
warm cookies anyway it was a completely
great really bad idea but I it was
fabulous we got a lot of warm cookies um
mi t--'s website was really dorky this
is what the long now looked like in 1998
and so we basically put this together
and then we started making it available
as a as a resource called the wayback
machine to make it freely available
again and the way we've sort of survived
in that whole realm is we're pretty
responsive to people wanting us to take
things off um so if it's if it wasn't
meant for the ages then we'll take down
web pages but mostly people use it to
get their own materials back out and
they it gets about 500,000 users a day
but I was really surprised about that it
gets that much use it gets um it's about
a through a six petabyte database it's
about a hundred and fifty billion pages
and it gets about a thousand queries a
second so it's kind of fun in terms of
the sort of magnum scale of it but it's
still possible by a small group like us
there's um some some things that I would
use to justify making such a collection
this is a press release by the President
of the United States saying when he is
standing around on a aircraft carrier
that announcing combat operations in
Iraq have ended and a couple days later
it was changed to say that major combat
operations in Iraq had and there was no
mention that there was a change to the
press release it just changed and if
we're not gonna live in a perpetual
present or when people can go and change
the past at will we're gonna need to
have third party
that go and record things and make them
enduringly available we're starting to
work with more organizations to build
collections to make sure we've got the
right stuff we have an archiving tool
and this is when events like the
Japanese tsunami happened started
working with organizations around the
world to find what are the key sites
that will be about that and be able to
record them and so we recorded a lot of
Japanese materials with the cooperation
of the National Library in Japan which
they didn't feel comfortable collecting
themselves on given their copyright laws
so we collected it and then we went back
and donated it to them they were very
thankful why they think that's well
anyway we're all around we're very happy
that that kind of thing is going on so
even the web is doable rare books and
letters we're starting to get better at
more personal archives and the like with
digitizing stations that are basically
glorified camera stands with high-end
digital cameras and good workflows and
metadata so the idea of even bringing
our personal materials online is doable
so I tried to give you a breadth of all
of the media types and all of the
published works of humankind and try to
argue that technologically financially
even law wise that we can go and make
these things available and so that I
think is in a change to be able to leave
Joe and say okay what if we did the
whole darn thing then the next question
is okay now you have a lot of it online
what are you going to do with it how do
you preserve it and there are a couple
different ways you can try bearing in
the desert which is kind of the rosetta
stone or is that a disc kind of idea or
you can try to keep it in flow in flux
and but if we're going to build the
Library of Alexandria version two we
should probably think about that
well what's Library of Alexandria
version one best known for burning right
it's best known for not being here
anymore on there it was the center of
learning of the ancient world and
there's only eight pieces of papyrus
that are in any
place now that are believed to have been
in the ancient Library of Alexandria at
that time and they're basically little
scholar notes that got taken away it's
oh it's so completely gone um if they
just made a copy
um so India and China were up and
running through that whole period and
and they didn't have a real tradition of
burning libraries like anyway um so
there's um so there's so making copies
so when the new Library of Alexandria
came around they contacted us and I said
yes let's let's participate in help and
we said ok for your opening they reorder
tected the first floor of it and this is
a picture in the library of Alexander in
2002 of our Collette our web collection
or a movie collection as it stood then
so there they took the whole thing and
served it as a wayback machine to the
world to have a whole replicated copy in
a different location so we were very
happy on that they were interested in
doing this and it was a fabulous couple
months to help rebuild the Library of
Alexandria this is what the first parts
of it looked like in Amsterdam so now
we've got San Francisco Alexandria and
Amsterdam so we have an earthquake zone
the Middle East and a flood zone what
could go wrong so I had five or six
regional areas that were really working
to go and archive their own regions and
then do large-scale swap agreements
between each other so that as iron
curtains go up and down or disasters or
governments go and burn libraries
whatever that those um we'd be there to
basically help rebuild if we had five or
six copies of this I think I could sleep
but we're only sort of you know ours
plus a couple a couple of starts so
we're not really quite there yet but I
think that's probably the best
opportunity for lasting three centuries
that that I know of this is what a
couple years ago when we were about two
petabytes two thousand terabytes goes
mega Giga tera petaa so this is two two
two bytes and this is what the wayback
machine looks like so if you want to
know how big is the web okay you have to
ask me
glad you asked the web is 20 feet by 8
feet by 8 feet and it sits outside if
you use the wayback machine you're using
that computer that is a computer that's
a shipping container that's full of
computers that are full of computers and
full of disk drives and it operates as
an enormous Database Machine and we
think that's idle pretty cool and so Sun
helped us buy this thing and it's now on
the Oracle campus and that's pretty neat
our next generation we were able to make
them pretty again and make a sort of
blinking machine and put it in our new
building and so this is what the
internet archive collections now look
like and what's kind of neat is every
light whenever a light blinks it's
either somebody uploading or downloading
something from the Internet Archive so
it's got this sort of lively sort of
look to it to make kind of a library
that's that's kind of fun to be around
so the idea of preserving this is doable
you have to every five years move to the
next generation keep copies in in other
places and love them
the idea is to need it if we don't need
it it will disappear that's how every
basically the history of libraries is
they get burned they get burned in
general by governments because they
don't want them around
they're usually sorry about it a hundred
years later but it's too late so the
idea is to design for it and try to keep
these things in use and around but we
found that just keeping digital
materials isn't enough that we're now
accumulating physical books and also
libraries are throwing out books out of
velocity and so we're since we're
digitizing books we wanted to keep the
physical versions that became digital
just to have sort of the tie between the
physical world and the whole provenance
so we've seen things now from books to
microfilm to CD ROMs
and then to hard drives and then to hard
drives and then hard drives and we
basically keep all of those different
versions and we're just launched this
last year a physical archive in Richmond
California that's basically modified
shipping containers that are temperature
and humidity controlled to be able to do
high-density book music video microfilm
and computer storage so we basically
keep all of the different versions of
these things and over time this
collection on which is about 30 40 foot
shipping containers will hold about 1
million books
it's got now three hundred and fifty
thousand cataloged ones and a couple
hundred thousand on yet to be catalogued
books but that kind of density and that
kind of cost can make it so we don't
have to throw books away the Friends of
the San Francisco Public Library book
sale that was here in Fort Mason a
couple of months ago all the books that
didn't sell they donated to us it was
about a hundred and thirty thousand
books and about half of those we didn't
have yet those are the books were
keeping and then we donate the other
half to other nonprofits so we're
starting to collect we're trying to
collect one physical copy of all the
books of the world and we think that we
should be able to get up to ten million
books that's sort of we're not going to
get to the collections of the Library of
Congress or the like but will be a
different kind of collection that will
have a different kind of access method
and model so what I tried to argue is
that we can take all of the published
works of a of humankind and put them
online we can make them accessible and
we can make them persist over time
universal access to all knowledge I
think it could be one of the great
things humans have ever done I think it
could live on in the mythology of
humankind of the Library of Alexandria a
man on the moon I think the I it's one
of the things and I think it's one of
the things our generation can do for the
next is to sort of declare an open
society really open to all and in
closing a carved above the the the door
and the pittsburgh carnegie library
carnegie one of the most capitalistic
guys has ever been produced by this
world he put free to the people thank
you very much
let's go sit well you got everybody
charged up me too
what should we all rush out and do well
if sorry was that it that I just killed
all my later no this is two hundred
thousand books which is actually kind of
interesting it's for it's a four
terabyte hard drive well and at this
point you can put these are of scanned
color PDFs that are searchable if you
plug it into your Mac and wait long
enough which is a long time then you can
use spotlight to actually search inside
two hundred thousand books so so what
should we do well don't throw things
away that are valuable and in probably
new in different ways if you're going to
throw them away throw them towards us so
we're taking donations of things but
also of bits and carve your own legacy
if you will your offerings to next
generations and put them in long-term
places on the internet archive strives
for that long now strives for that
nonprofits seem to last longer than than
for profits so think about the longer
term in terms of what it is your
offerings are to people now your
children and maybe even to people you
don't even know where do you send stuff
where do we send digits you can send
stuff to us if you've got a large enough
collection we'll come and help pack it
up and move it out archive.org you can
come visit us in the Richmond facility
and we have a free lunch every Friday so
please come in it's it's it's it's it's
fun there is no such thing as a free
lunch
[Laughter]
you were flying in the face of that
whole story of there is no such thing as
a free lunch this is three at all
there's a free doll and it works guess
what I found in my innocent Mike
if you give things away things go better
and better and better I you know I've
run companies started companies and
they've generally been relatively small
and now this sort of give everything
away and we've grown much larger than
any of the companies I've built it's a
business model that works information
wants to you mentioned this before the
talk we were noticing together that
businesses we've been involved in have
kind of limited lifespans and the
nonprofit's we've been involved in at
times have much longer lifespans how
come some of its expectation some of its
that we I think there's this exponential
growth thing I think use of companies is
[Music]
when people start talking about an exit
that's the weirdest thing I mean I love
these terms like exits and resources so
the idea of building stable things that
are a certain size so buying your own
building and sort of limits your growth
but Peachy I don't want to work with you
know so you know they're also they're
thinner skin they're easier to work with
others nonprofits have been very
interesting and the growth of high-tech
nonprofits in the Bay Area this is a
different subject but I find very
interesting and some of the most
interesting things are going on within
the Wikipedia's okay the Wikipedia well
Zillah
Computer History you guys who else GFF
is an is a nonprofit law firm mm-hmm
that basically serves the open world the
Apache foundation Linux Foundation the
there's is C which is a non-profit ISP
so there's these folks that are doing
real infrastructure that are lasting
decades and a lot of the things that
they came from you know are sort of
flash in the pans I think also we've
been finding that it's it's getting
easier to hire really good people
because they want to work on something
that will last if you worked in a.com
sometimes the the only thing you really
have to show for it is a few pages in
the wayback machine and that's kind of
you know that was two years of my
life you know well so the idea of
working on things that are likely to get
out to people and last is a draw I get
it
nonprofit is the after market for the
for-profit because they happened in your
case she made some money doing some
things with Waze and LexA and stuff like
that and some of that money is playing
into the Internet Archive I presume some
of these people who want to go work for
the dot orgs formerly worked at the
dot-coms and are squared away enough
they're not gonna try to get rich at
internet I'll foundation right some to
some extent if people are fortunate
enough to get rich that's that's
terrific
um but mostly not mostly there are
people that are just you know working
along and trying to make it go um I
actually I think the nonprofit's are
more like how organizations used to be
100 years ago before everything's a
joint-stock company they're called
trusts we had some troubles with them
than you the antitrust anyway there I
think there's a we kind of went wrong by
building these corporations because
they're very easy to merge so that we've
sort of commodified groups of people
nonprofits are unbel and i think that's
one of the things that makes them
enduring so i think they're a lot like
anyway they're do something profound
here so you're telling me the Internet
Archive doesn't have an exit strategy
I'll see you at the exit so it's just
endless entrance that's pretty yeah okay
don't works it because there's no X it's
all entrance a couple questions from
Tristan and Chris both asking basically
how do you check for duplicates in
multiple versions of original material
ah
duplicates um so we've always tried to
deduplicate like the web collection um
as best we can tell about half of our
collection is a duplicate but on the
average life of a web page is about a
hundred days as best we can tell is that
changed over time
I don't know study of our our
collections uh because we're usually
just too busy just trying to get it to
work keep up um when did you come up
with that number a number of years ago
uh 99 okay so this is a research
opportunity if somebody adjusts the
number not
might be shorter right so I don't know
what would be your guess more and more
of the pages are computer-generated and
so those may not be content fully
different but from a computer
perspective so it'll be shorter more and
more the web is sort of this as
effervescent computer-generated stuff
but so I would say if we were to do the
same count in the same way we're we're
probably getting shorter and shorter
what suggest another whole kind of way
back research could be done of the sort
of the nature of pages how that's
changing over time yes you know what do
you notice so far on that things are
becoming more active I think we need to
archive active services so people have
built websites but they want to do
something next it used to be that you
could just you know write up your paper
or your book and you put on the shell
from the librarians job was sort of take
care of it right you can go and work on
something else but that doesn't really
work on the web hmm all right if you you
know don't keep it up it'll die it'll
fall over and people get you know
they'll email you and they still have
you know they can pissed um so you can't
leave things so how can you go and hand
off a working service to a library
mmm-hmm that I think is is the next
thing that we really need in terms of
the web is archiving living working
services there's archive with an X which
is an important
pre-publication server that's part of
the physics world in the math world by
this unbelievably great guy Paul
Ginsberg and he's been trying to put it
into the Cornell library mm-hm so that
they'll take over and it's not a good
fit but they're trying they're really
giving a good shot the financial models
don't work some of that this is the
general things so existing libraries and
active running digital resources mm-hmm
don't quite fit yet so we need in either
new generation of libraries or throw the
way or make that work how much that can
be done by robots I mean could you have
a basically extinct website that has a
bunch of links on it the links are
mostly dead now can a robot keep those
links somewhat alive oh sure they can
keep the links alive but how do you keep
the the question-answering part the
search engines the databases how do you
keep it getting updated mmhmm right so
and so it doesn't become
so this isn't something that's you know
you want something that continues on
being what it was now I mean a lot of
the web server a lot of the websites we
use have active parts themselves and
that might be able to be continued on
right now the Internet Archive is taking
snapshots of things how they looked but
not how they act you know and that's not
an easy thing or you have any cases yet
of that working of no and otherwise
about to dive website being able to stay
alive well just this the links like geo
cities which was a very major thing in
the in the 1990s that was going down so
we worked very hard and with a bunch of
very active volunteers basically tried
to grab it mp3.com which was not very
good music oh there's a lot of it though
and a lot of people's creativity so we
worked very hard to collect that when
Yahoo video is going down Google Video
mm-hmm
and we're trying like heck to try to
keep up with a critical mass of YouTube
so but but mostly this is trying to just
keep up with the with the collections
but it's getting big question from Ken
Pro Chris key have you given any thought
to capturing the worlds of genetic
information
there's GenBank out there yes what lode
my this oh we haven't really been doing
much in that domain there there is a lot
of folks that are doing scientific data
sets and trying to archive those and
they have real problems and they're
really difficult to figure out how to
reuse how do you go and make things such
that somebody can use it again and it's
challenging so we haven't we've we've
got some things we've got map
collections we've got images of the
earth that people put on us but there
are other folks that are really doing
much better jobs of a lot of the
scientific data sets we're mostly doing
cultural materials and until we do that
well I think we should just stick to our
knitting so Laura asks are you doing
your digitizing physical objects
speaking of cultural things physical
objects there's a project that I find
it's pretty neat there
California Academy of Science Conte
sciences wants to digitize all of their
ants and they're doing a great job
they've got this brian fisher's in the
audience built this machine that takes a
tile of pictures from lots of different
angles to build up a model of ants
because they actually have drawers and
drawers and drawers of these things and
across all of the the scientific
organization the Natural History
Museum's there are tons of these things
and so there's work to do on that we've
done some experiments on that but we
haven't really come along very far it's
mostly in the grant-making but what's
helped on there is people going and
saying let's do it all mm-hmm if you you
say let's do it all you get around all
of the problems of wow my ants more
important than your aunt it's like no no
well just do want to love them and and
that just sort of sets the bar and also
keeps the bickering down and you just
have to get the technology to to work
that's this is - Kevin Kelly's point
that all is different than most yes do
you collect art as small doing so we
look like a lot of Britney Spears photos
we collect whatever it is that's out
there we don't really have a good idea
where we're mostly oriented okay what do
you say no - come on no what do I offer
and you say sorry we don't do that mmm
smelly cheese yeah no we have a lot of
porn a lot of porn so what do we
basically been trying to do the
published works of humankind what some
of the things that we don't do are
things that weren't meant to be
published so we don't collect for
instance on facebook pages that weren't
public hmm we don't want to be spooky we
don't want to be the place that you
don't want stuff to be there and so how
do we deal with that I I don't exactly
know because we're starting to deal with
things that are given to us that are
then made public later
but we'd really try very hard to just
make things public and really have that
be the idea I think of dark archives
which we talked about before is actually
a really bad idea um right um
because if you leave something dark for
a while there's a very good chance it
will never come back either you just
can't figure it out you didn't record it
well in the first place um it was at
last we're going into so on so finally
died and we get to go into who really
killed Kennedy or whatever the hell it
is there it is well we can't read it
yeah backup tapes have got a long
history of like not really being there
so keeping things in circulation keeping
things loved I think is absolutely
critical having some communities and
having an idea that it isn't all dark
and all like that there are things that
are just going to be interesting to
scholars and the like um they there's
this idea that you know one digital copy
means that it's everywhere it's like
it's not just not true um so the idea of
having these materials and having them
be available but just not available very
well I think as though as the way to go
dark archives I I will suggest is not a
good idea not that you could have robot
dark lovers that would keep the dark
archives alive I house house reading
house reading your old email from 20
years ago oh my god not very good yeah
right you know just try reading floppies
I did this stuff it it dies really fast
especially in the digital world and if
it's not accessible also you can't get
the funding to keep it used so there are
these organizations that are funded to
try to keep things dark but if it's not
loved
you're not gonna attract great people um
and it's it's it's it's not going to
also if you take some things out of
circulation there's a Mike Holly
suggested that on the bombing of
Cambodia
mm-hm during the that period of American
history in Cambodian history um
that the people lost how to dance hmm
and so bringing it back too late you're
sort of teaching it as
it's a foreign language so the idea is
to keep things in circulation and it's
not there's I so we've over proper tries
information that there's a role for
continuous access especially by groups
of people that aren't trying to
commercially exploit we're being told
that it isn't really storage it's
Flowage that keeps things going yes
that's a that's right that and that
helps it being migrated from platform
platform and you're finding out you know
the usefulness is which they keep being
new ones and all the ones that I off we
don't character search yeah it's an on
and on and if it starts being really
profitable then you figure it out but an
awful lot of this stuff yeah it'll it'll
keep bumping along Nick asked can an
individual declare themselves a library
and upload copies of their books to the
archive sure I that's but yes you can
you can upload things to the internet
archive well we'll try to preserve them
forever and make them as available as we
can and a lot of this is sort of an
ongoing global negotiation really and
we're trying to do this sort of bend not
break approach like when we started
getting going on the live music
collections we you know there were a
couple bands that pulled things down off
of it and we said okay you know no
problem and the idea is to just try to
have people feel like they're not being
locked into forever in certain things so
if you donate bits or or scan things yes
in terms of declaring yourself a library
it brings up this question of what is a
library when we started out there was a
question of sort of what is a library
and so I asked these lawyers I think was
at EF F what is it and they basically
said walk like a duck quack like a duck
here duck there isn't there wasn't real
restrictions and you didn't have to be
blessed by anybody and I think that's
the right way to go otherwise little
organizations like the Internet Archive
were at least it was 15 years ago might
not have been able to get off the ground
but having some level of knowing of
being a library did help for instance
with facing down the FBI Barry Gordon
asks you Google crawlers help you or get
in the way and this sort of raises the
general question of Google Google visa
vie you know
kind of ah Google if um Wow what what an
organization um what a blessing and a
curse
um a lot of the reason why the internet
archive's web collections work is
because of the search engines in general
we kind of follow along after the search
engines and basically is its quid quo
pro between the search engines and the
content websites where the search
engines are allowed to make a copy to
basically make it searchable but they're
supposed to pass the traffic back to the
website and it's because there's this
separation that we can be kind of like
them and collect this stuff up so we
really need the search engines to win
but we need them to be separate because
as the search engines and the content
companies become one then the motivation
for those companies to allow them to be
crawled by others drops so Google wants
to crawl you but they don't want you to
crawl them they make it difficult for us
to crawl YouTube um and they don't want
people to crawl their books so the even
the public domain wants so they put up
CAPTCHAs so you have to be a human prove
you're a human to be able to get public
domain books this doesn't make any sense
and it's hmm I tend to stay away from
the evil thing there's an politicians
that have used those words a lot I don't
know those it's it sort of sets a bad
precedent anyway um but it's I think
trying to keep these things separate the
search separate from the content
organizations I think would make a lot
of sense so I think that there's been a
bit of overreach on the part of Google I
think all in all they're maturing along
but I hope that there's it's one of the
great things about Silicon Valley's is
it's a beehive there's lots of
organizations you have to figure out how
to work with each other it's not just
one mammoth
organization and so I think the idea is
keep things small keep things
lightweight keep it so that there's
reproducible interfaces between
organizations and smarts um so that
there can be new players and they're not
sort of encrusted in one so this raises
this question of right sizing for even
an archive itself which is
you mentioned the negotiation that is
sort of constant though you know what
things get to stay on and the
negotiating probably with Google about
this that and the other thing with FBI
at a certain time you must limitation
the Internet Archive must be the amount
of human time you guys can put on
negotiation basically yes and is that
changing or is it a constant or the rest
of our life or um we're sort of well I
hope we won't grow terribly large we'd
have no lawyers on staff it's good we
want to keep it that way you're just
squeal in the ffs yeah yeah all right in
public now you know there's actually
it's so anyway please donate to uff they
they they really do help a lot of
organizations um so what's the right
size of the Internet Archive I like the
size of sort of 40 people within kind of
a high-tech environment the Internet
Archive is total about a hundred and
fifty people that working most of them
are in scanning centers um it's about a
twelve million dollar-a-year
organization now most of the money comes
from libraries paying us to collect the
world wide web or digitize books for
them some money comes from foundations a
bunch comes from just donations from
from our users patrons on they keep us
alive so it's that sort of scale and
we're trying not to grow so quite
Patrick asks a question do you see
copyright and/or intellectual property
which is endlessly fraught as near as I
can tell
ever going away ever being unfried I'm
stalled man desk in the resource almond
lichens and not using the words
intellectual property together I think
it gives too much the idea of ideas as
real estate is sort of I don't know so
so I used copyright copyright patent and
trademark copyrights are protects an old
business model in terms of how things
worked in terms of keeping people
productive in separate organizations I
think things need to change around a bit
but
less than the way we thought there were
these sort of waves of going and
rewriting copyright law in 1990 in 1976
the copyright law was rewritten with the
response somewhat to the Xerox machine
mm-hm and they did this weary weird
thing they they made it instead of going
and having to write a little C and
sending a copy into the Library of
Congress to cop cop get copyright they
said everything's copyrighted why I mean
I don't know I think it was just easy to
just write the what's that all that you
idea and all sorts of things became
copyrighted they didn't need need to be
copyrighted but it's because we have
this sort of corporate influence on the
government that it's gonna be almost
impossible to get that that really bad
idea undone so I don't know how to take
on us practice is it changing you deal
with the whole world now yeah different
different places
no that's the Europe was ahead of us on
that one China they they're all getting
slammed into the United States system by
these trade agreements promulgated by
the United States and they're pushing
things on them that would never get
through Congress so I think this
copyright thing is just a mess
but it is a I'd say where we're seeing
two regimes we're seeing absolute
control and we're seeing the more the
youtubes and internet archive's and you
know the the the general and it's
they're sort of splitting and it's sort
of splitting kind of like our politics
in such a way that it's very difficult
to have real discussions back and forth
when I think actually these worlds could
work actually well together publishing
in libraries have always worked in
parallel it's a the three billion to
four billion that I mentioned before
that libraries spent on publishers
products is about ten or fifteen percent
of the book publishing industry Wow
that's non-trivial yeah and it keeps a
whole level of guarantees for publishers
to go and get books out there you know
but we're having a very difficult time
as a digital library buying books from
publishers this doesn't make any sense
we've sort of gotten just kind of
wrapped in sort of into much more of a
Waring position it just in general means
archive gets hold of penguin and wants
to buy a copy of my book penguin raises
fusses with you yes and they were
generally we were
going around and we're having bills
fallout away I have a million dollars in
my back pocket really to go and buy
electronic books such that we will buy
it and then we'll lend it one person at
a time all right one person at a time
and they can charge more than then the
cover price you know whatever let
capitalism figured out we just want to
have a set of books and on the Khalifah
which is a consortium of California
Public Library said Brewster if you can
go and make that work we'll put millions
and millions and millions of dollars
into things that way it's what way the
libraries want to work but many of the
publishers are saying oh the fringe ones
are saying yes um and so we're getting
that going we've got hundreds not
thousands Mike how many four or five
hundred different titles that we've now
bought in such a way that we bought it
like we bought the old-style book we own
it and we can land out one copy at a
time but it's just it's not working
terribly well yet we think that that
model works pretty well so if you have a
popular book you get paid more that's a
good thing um and there's somebody
that's gonna take long term care of it
mm-hm
but it's not there's there's still
business model problems the advertising
model it builds things like radio
television magazines newspapers we've
seen that movie before it's kind of
crappy so um the idea of royalty based
systems which is how the print world
grew up brought us books which I think
actually are pretty nifty
all in all um and also movies so that's
our more paper something but how do we
get libraries and publishing working
better together we're still in the flux
of it I'm I'm a little frustrated you
know it's 2011 shouldn't we be past this
by now but we're not it's still ongoing
so the digital age basically it's been
going for maybe half a century now I
said in 1984 information wants to be
free that this steve wozniak information
wants to be expensive and those who are
fighting it out in 84 there's a long
time ago and they're still fighting it
out so it's it's judging by the past
they will fight it out forever what the
hell well given two data points since
you draw line well I don't know
I think I think we can figure this thing
out I I think we're gonna get um I'm an
optimist on this one I think that we're
gonna be able to have that Library of
Alexandria that we're that we've been
looking for that there's a mechanism
there's enough money out there there's
the political will to live in an open
society that yes there's enough money we
have to figure out how to distribute it
better we probably have too many lawyers
on staff not enough business people and
people trying to make things actually
work but I think we've got it I think we
can make this go I think the key thing
to try to avoid is centralized points of
control I know the tipping point will be
when there's more engineers than there
are lawyers Kevin Kelly asks what
mechanism we have you engineered to make
sure the Internet Archive outlasts you
do you have long-term funding do you
have a successor how old are you 51 um
we've got sort of an endowment model but
no it hasn't been sort of the real
obsession in terms of succession things
just trying to get it to work would like
to see lots of different internet
archives and Internet Archive like
things are you generating those well
we're trying in different places then we
started that one in Amsterdam and I'm
trying to get a separate life for today
yeah they're they're completely separate
life and they're funded within their own
structures and boards that are
separating started one in Canada and
it's starting to separate so that that
approach um and then the one of the
things that like one of the things the
Internet Archive does that I'd like to
to try to find some mechanism is to keep
it pushing the edge trying to trying new
and different things and we've seen a
lot more a lot of older organizations
they often become more conservative so
how do you sort of keep things pushing
along and do things just need to die and
get reborn is that a way to do it or is
there some way of engineering it so that
characteristic of doing something how do
you keep things how do you keep things
refreshing themselves how do you keep an
organization for
ever young are you supposed to answer
that kind of question oh that's it next
time don't know the answer to that but I
think it's it's a really worthwhile
thing I think it's picking good people
and making sure your mission is right
but I don't have a good answer what's
the median age of people at the Internet
Archive 40 35 younger yeah we're looking
at some of the Internet Archive folks up
something in there okay I'm something in
there that bears relation is near same
town one of the reasons universities
keeping themselves going it's they
keeping having a fresh set of
undergraduates that you know keeps
things fresh and inventing new
disciplines and so on Dave Marlon has a
good final question for this year what
do you want most they've not got yet and
why and how can we help you get it oh
softball
[Laughter]
I think the big step for us is to figure
out how to be used more how do the real
aspect that I think we need to do next
is to try to figure out how to be more
useful to people we get used by about 2
million people a day but I bet most of
the people in this room haven't you
haven't consciously used the Internet
Archive right ever I am or so how do we
do it unconsciously I didn't know that
happening a lot of sites directly link
into resources on the Internet Archive
and you'd never know it
aha so you don't private label no we
don't put splotches on things you know
it so we're sort of a backing store or
sort of media for people that want to do
this and can't afford to do it
themselves so I I guess the big thing
that love ideas on or efforts on is to
try to pick make this sort of thing
blended in more how would we blend in to
the flickers the Twitter's the
Facebook's how do we make it so that
people can hit a button and then
digitally archived their their wordpress
blogs into this kind of thing how do we
sort of become much more woven in to the
world i we can go in and and find things
to digitize and put things up and and
and and we could always use money and
all those things but I think the idea is
how do we go and make a world that has
commercial entities lots of commercial
entities and different nonprofit
entities work together really
productively seamlessly to make a world
that both has the energy and jazz and
gasoline of the commercial world and the
longevity and security and and
thoughtfulness of the nonprofit world
kind of all working for us in an
integrated digital ecology we we had it
growing up within the physical ecology
what does that ecology look like now and
how can the Internet Archive play an
interesting role going forward so can
you imagine like a you know a button on
most of those sites where content is
being generated where
can sort of hit that button and it's
archived from the or yeah that kind of
thing we've had yahoo has been great
whenever they're gonna take down a
service they come to us and tell us you
know hey we're gonna take down the
service you better archive the hell out
of it um so so that's good
we got built into some of the bittley's
you know those Earl shorteners on
Twitter
those are mappings between short urls
and a resource mm-hmm
but if that company goes away all of
those break so they donate those to us
such that when they go out of business
oh they always do um then we bring them
back to life and so we've done that now
for a few urlshortener so that's
building together but I think we can do
things much more integrated just so that
libraries publishing is sort of in in
the same role or how are we keeping our
own digital personal digital archives
how does that work it's not working
terribly well now so how do we build
things such that the Internet Archive in
the or a brethren start to work with
with those things that make it so that
our digital lives that are now
splattered all over these different
services yet have a long term life that
aren't gonna sort of betray us and when
we're trying to run well that's the
question
now you're talking dark archive again
you have people worried about with
Facebook and everything else how much
privacy either they've already lost they
expect to lose more and that you want to
have all the really personal stuff how
are you gonna protect it mmm you don't
know don't know yet but if there's oh if
there's an answer on those sorts of
fronts I think we'd have a more robust
digital environment that frankly has a
lot of the protections that we had 50
years ago and we'd be able to to live
out and grow and exploit having lots of
people being interconnected computers to
help us there and not lose things 50
years ago 50 years from now so long now
we do that
what's your sense of our not what'll
happen 50 years from now that's
especially in this domain probably
little idle but what sort of formal
responsibilities do we have now to the
people who like us but we're totally
unlike us 50 years from now might want I
mean you're sort of talking universal
access for everybody for free for all
time and that covers it does that cover
it it might I'm just checking the the
new entrants in this world are are the
computers mm-hmm and they're the ones
that I think are really going to be the
major readers of our books if not all if
not already so the the the world that
we're trying to prepare for is not just
when humans are the patrons of the
library but it's when computers come by
to try to learn and that's our future
user community if you will and those AIS
will sometimes be kind of independent
and sometimes be just search engines
that provide new and different types of
resources for people but preparing our
materials to be used in fairly different
ways um is how we're trying to keep
ourselves relevant going forward already
you know life without the search engines
is pretty hard to imagine right or even
life without Wikipedia or if you take
Citibank and you have the choice as a
shareholder to kill all the people or
kill the computers which would you do
right um and so I I think the shift is
happened um and I'm not suggesting then
I I think are the next generation that
really gets to use these things are our
computers and I find that very exciting
well let's pursue this just a shot
further next fall Tim O'Reilly is going
to be doing one of these things
and the title that he plans to use is
the emerging global brain okay which
isn't just robots getting access to
everything but everything in a sense by
virtue of it being everything and
digital and increasingly aware and
language capable and all this kind of
stuff it starts to have seriously
aggregate brain like capabilities mmm is
what we're talking about here feeding
into that and oh yeah that's where I
started on so I started at the MIT
artificial intelligence lab I was born
in a test-tube in AI lab studying under
Danny Hillis and Marvin Minsky and we
seemed absolutely data starved I mean
there were a bowl a thinking machine
right and it didn't know anything I know
it was and so I said all right well if
we're gonna bring up you know our new
overlords um let's let's at least have
it read good books so I think you know
how hard could that be and I really
didn't think was gonna take that long
and now we're still at it but but we're
making pretty good progress um I don't
quite think of things in this sort of
autonomous AI kind of way how sort of
versus the spaceman war um maybe that'll
happen but you know I think I'm just
much more symbiotic Emily these days so
I think the but the idea of having these
materials be used in fun and I think
we're seeing it already I think there's
just the the wondrous things and wacko
things that we're seeing out there on
the Internet are because of a lot of
this compute power and the internet in
the internet interconnectivity we just
need to make it a deeper resource right
so I've got two kids and they're not
going to the library in the same way I
did
they're using whatever's online that's
what they're learning from and it's
pretty shallow I mean you can learn all
you want about you know some old
connector technology but if you want to
go and learn about some real it sits in
libraries and it's not in digital form
so I think we're bringing up kids
without
the depth and xx sent Michael asked a
father of digital libraries said he
worries about the 20th century he thinks
the 19th century will be online and
before um he thinks the 21st century
will be online but the 20th century may
not be and the 20th century was have a
screwed up century that I think we want
to make sure we learn the lessons from
that one and have the next generation do
so or we're gonna get the generation we
deserve so this is interesting is you're
basically saying that in a way the 21st
century will be self archiving and
already yes but archiving the 20th
century is going to take four digits
effort it's gonna take some bold
maneuvers um and I think we've got some
of the paths through it we get some
money going back and forth keep the
publishers alive we need to publishers
and authors still get paid right gets
paid off get a check every so often for
the books you we want to continue that
going forward but we've got to get all
of it online right now because we could
spend a whole generation bickering among
ourselves hmm and they won't have access
they won't use the deep literature of
understanding the depression or the Dust
Bowl or a lot of things that we can note
world war two there are lessons that we
can learn out of these things that are
right now being recontextualized by new
people but what looking at the source
documents make a whole lot of sense I
think that's some of the reason why the
pray linger old movies are so empower
'full is they're not recontextualized
they're not a new documentary brought to
you that by Chevron they are the
original source documents and that
bringing all of that online and making
it available to this next generation I
find a very urgent problem not the next
50 years now we've got to get this
solved universal raw data thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you